the confirmation hearings for contangi
brown jackson took a shocking turn
yesterday when republicans made the bold
and controversial decision
to ask the judge about her resume and
her judicial philosophy rulings her
fundamental beliefs
breaking from recent tradition they for
whatever reason did not ask jackson how
many beers she drank in college nor did
they inspect her high school yearbook
for potential vulgarities uh democrats
claim that jackson has been treated
unfairly one can only assume that this
is what they mean she's been treated
like a judge seeking the highest
judicial appointment in the land and not
like an alleged criminal on trial by a
kangaroo court
that's what essentially separates the
way republicans handle these sorts of
things from the way democrats handle
them but of course it's already known
ahead of time that any line of
questioning directed at jackson will be
out of bounds and racist
at least any questioning outside of
questions like what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream and
have you always been this wonderful
the left made that explicitly clear from
the outset though they didn't need to be
explicit this is how the game is played
according to the long established rules
yet in spite of the inherent racism of
demanding that a black woman explain
herself when all she wants to do is
become a supreme court justice
there is based on her record and her
worldview
quite a lot to explain
many of the questions about jackson um
and and to her as well have focused
rightfully so on her lengthy history of
leniency towards child sex predators
especially people who consume child
pornography who are also child sex
predators by definition
the rnc research account lists several
cases where jackson passed down a
sentence significantly below
federal sentencing guidelines in fact
this is how she handled every child porn
case she encountered every single one
she passed down a sentence below federal
guidelines so for example in one case a
man who had images of uh eight-year-old
children
pornographic images was supposed to be
sentenced to 10 years according to the
guidelines she gave him three months
in another a predator with 48 files of
child porn on his computer was subject
to 97 months in prison
jackson cut that into a third giving him
28.
um in still another case a pervert who
posted a uh pornographic image of a
five-year-old was given by jackson the
lowest possible sentence allowed by the
law just 60 months
now one thing you might take away from
this
is that the federal guidelines are far
too lenient already
i see no reason why why child porn users
and distributors should not be given
mandatory life sentences this should be
like a one strike in your out kind of
situation these are not people we need
in society
you do something like that it should be
okay we don't need you
in society you're gone and you're never
coming back
and yet
the soft guidelines were still not soft
enough for jackson who seems to have a
soft spot in her heart for child sex
perverts
now what what can she say for herself to
justify this well to explain at least
one of these cases
she said that the lenient sentence was
due in part to the child predators
diplomas and certificates listen
he presented all of his diplomas and
certificates and the things that he had
done
and argued
consistent with what i was seeing in the
record
that this particular defendant
had gotten into this in a way that was i
thought inconsistent with some of the
other cases that i had seen part of what
a judge is doing
as
required by congress
is
thinking about
this case
thinking about unwarranted sentencing
disparities that's in the statute other
cases other determinations that a judge
may have made about this
i don't remember in detail this
particular case but i do recall it being
unusual now at another point she argued
that her lighter touch on this issue has
sometimes been due to the disparities in
the system the fact that
the federal guidelines for child porn
sentencing were first established back
when child porn users had to obtain
images through the mail and this for
some reason is significant and it means
that sometimes the sentence should be
lighter than the guidelines allow let's
listen to that
as you said the guideline was based
originally on
a statutory scheme and on directives
specific directives by congress at a
time
in which
more serious child pornography
offenders were identified based on the
volume
based on the number of photographs that
they received in the mail and that made
totally total sense
before
when we didn't have the internet when we
didn't have distribution but the way
that the guideline is now structured
based on that set of circumstances
is leading to extreme disparities in the
system
because
it's so easy for people to get
volumes of this kind of material now
by computers
so it's not doing the work
of differentiating who is a more serious
offender in the way that it used to
so the commission has taken that into
account and and perhaps even more
importantly courts
are adjusting their sentences
in order to account for the changed
circumstances but it says nothing about
the court's view of the seriousness
of this offense
so the argument is that punishing
someone for each image they obtain was
fair back when they had to have the
images mailed to them but now that it's
so easy to get hundreds of images at
once it's not fair that's the argument
and it's a very very bad argument
and you know it's a bad argument because
over on cnn infamous public masturbator
jeffrey toobin was agreeing with it
it seems that tubin having already
displayed his tube on a zoom call is now
incapable of experiencing any further
shame or embarrassment either that or he
enjoys it the freak whatever his reasons
tuban with his hands suspiciously out of
view said this
can i just add one point about these
these kitty porn cases and this this
came up i remember when i was an
assistant us attorney back in the 90s is
that when those uh
when those uh sentencing guidelines were
written for those cases
that this was a time when uh the people
who committed these crimes would order
individual photos and and and get and
then get them usually through email
um and then uh they would be sentenced
based on the number of photos they
possessed this was all pre-internet
so
uh once the internet came in and and
people got
um access to hundreds and then thousands
of photos they would the the sentencing
guidelines would reflect hundreds and
then thousands of photos federal judges
have been struggling with the issue of
how do you create a fair system that was
designed pre-internet that was
yet you have to sentence people post
internet and what i thought chairman
durbin pointed out is that judges across
the country
including republican appointed judges
have been saying look we can't apply the
rules um
pre that were designed pre-internet for
an internet society and many judges have
been giving somewhat less sentences as a
result
now far be it for me to get into an
argument with the sort of man who
doesn't wear
pants to a work meeting
especially when the argument is about
pornography but you know i'm not
convinced by this reasoning if anything
it seems clear to me the sentences
should be harsher now
because of the ease of access
it's exactly the reason that they're
calling for lighter sentences that's why
there should be harsher sentences
because it necessitates a greater level
of deterrence it means that we we must
make an even more drastic example out of
each offender
because of how easy this stuff is to
obtain
the message from society should be
we find a file of child porn on your
computer and you're done forever your
life is over
yet both jackson and tuban believe that
the more
crime the more that this crime
proliferates the more common it becomes
the less we should penalize it
now one might wish that this is about as
weird as things would get but judge
jackson is at bottom a leftist and that
means that the moral bewilderments and
intellectual incoherence goes much
deeper i mean this is a woman who is
tragically confused not just about the
concept of justice already a troubling
source of confusion for a judge but
also about the basic realities of life
including what what life even is and
when life begins and answer that
question here was her answer listen
when does life begin
in your opinion
senator
um
i don't
know
now there's of course no excuse for not
being able to answer that question the
only sensible starting point for life is
the moment when you come into existence
as a distinct human entity otherwise
known as conception
any other starting point that you might
choose will be necessarily arbitrary
there's only one solid firm
sensible starting point which is
conception but here's the thing
if she really doesn't know
when life begins
then that's all the more reason to be
stridently pro-life and anti-abortion
because by jackson's own words as far as
she knows
abortion might well be the murder of
human life i mean if she doesn't know
when life begins then she cannot say
that abortion does not murder
destroy human life
according to her the abortion industry
may well
have murdered 60 million human lives
since roe v wade
now i know for a fact not that it may
well have murdered 60 million human
lives but that it did
but you don't even need in order to get
to the pro-life
anti-abortion conclusion
you don't even need to go that far
the the the maybe the might that i don't
know
if you're a rational and moral person
that should be enough to get you to the
anti-abortion
conclusion
because if it's possible
even if it's even possible
that this mass genocide is happening if
it's a 50 50 toss-up as she seems to
think then the only moral and defensible
position to take is one of treating the
unborn child as human life to return to
an analogy that i've made before
supporting abortion when you don't know
when life begins it's like tossing a
live grenade into a room
when you don't know if there's anybody
in there or not you know it is at best
morally incoherent to say i don't know
when life begins but i support abortion
anyway
speaking of incoherent nothing of course
can top this
do you agree with justice ginsburg
that there are physical differences
between men and women that are enduring
senator
respectfully i
am not familiar with that particular
quote or case okay so it's hard for me
to
okay comment as to whether all right i'd
love to get your
your opinion on on that and you can
submit that
do you interpret justice ginsburg's
meaning of men and women as male and
female
again because i don't know the case i
don't know how i interpret it i need to
read the whole okay
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
senator in my work as a judge what i do
is i
address disputes if there's a dispute
about a definition people make arguments
and i look at the law and i decide
yeah i think we can officially now say
that the what is a woman movement has
begun when i started asking this
question years ago i dreamed i honestly
dreamed of a
moment just like this
where someone like this is asked a
question like that very simple
in this sort of context
because as we witness there the whole
house of cards comes tumbling down under
the very meager weight
of one extremely simple question
and the irony here is so rich
so grand that it's almost impossible to
fully appreciate and wrap your arms
around we've been breathlessly told that
we should celebrate jackson jackson's
nomination precisely because she's a
black woman
but jackson herself can't even tell us
what a woman is how can we celebrate the
nomination of a woman if the people
telling us to celebrate it can't define
the word
so they say celebrate her well why
because she's a woman damn it
what's that
i don't know
well okay then let me go get the
champagne
of course jackson's dodge is that she's
not a biologist
but saying you can't define woman
without a biology degree it's like
saying that you can't solve for five
plus five without a degree in
mathematics it's like saying you can't
define the word car if you're not a
mechanic or fish if you're not a marine
biologist
it's like saying you have to be a
world-class artist to explain what a
crayon is
this is all a bunch of unintelligible
irrational rambling nonsense
now is the fact that jackson doesn't
know what a woman is
relevant to her job
well yes i would think it's quite
relevant to a supreme court justice and
their job to know whether they have a
basic grasp on reality
and it's relevant for another reason
because we all know
that obviously she knows what a woman is
she knows the answer to the question
she's not that stupid
i mean if she doesn't know
then she is without a doubt the dumbest
supreme court nominee in the history of
the united states she is the dumbest
person to ever even be considered for
the job
and should be disqualified on those
grounds alone
but i'm going to give her more credit
than that
i don't think she's nearly that stupid
there's no way that she could make it as
far as she has
being that stupid
so no she knows what a woman is she
knows today
she's always known she'll know tomorrow
but she's so beholden to left-wing
orthodoxy so firmly embedded in that
world so committed to it that she will
pretend she doesn't know
humiliating herself on the national
stage in the process
that's what makes her dangerous on the
supreme court
and yet this question as i've been
insisting for years is the question
that single-handedly destroys gender
ideology and reveals leftism for what it
is
and what is it it's a movement of moral
and intellectual chaos
it rejects truth categorically
it's a form of madness ideological
madness madness that you choose to buy
into and adopt as your worldview
lunacy
it turned into a worldview is what
leftism is
most of all it's flimsy it's hollow at
its core
defeated by the most basic line of
inquiry
destroyed by questions
[Music]
questions that we just have to have
the guts to ask well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content